Il est temps de nous demander :
les suppositions et politiques
développées à la suite de ces événements tragiques
ont-elles amélioré notre sécurité ?
Ont-elles rendu nos sociétés, en Europe et aux États-Unis,
plus résistantes ?
J'ai travaillé toute ma vie
dans le domaine de la sécurité et de la défense
et je suis convaincue que maintenant, plus que jamais,
nous devons radicalement revoir
notre façon de penser et agir en matière de sécurité
et, en particulier, en matière de sécurité internationale.
Par sécurité internationale, je parle de ce que nous faisons,
comment nous préparons nos pays
à mieux répondre et éviter les menaces extérieures
et comment nous protégeons nos citoyens.
La clé de ces deux choses
est de nous concentrer sur la protection des civils
dans notre propre pays
et dans ceux où ils sont présents au nom de la sécurité.
Cette idée va à l'encontre du récit préétabli
que nous avons développé durant les 20 dernières années
au sujet de ce qu'est la sécurité et de comment l'obtenir,
mais ce récit est erroné et, pire, il est contre-productif.
Les 20 dernières années,
aux États-Unis et en Europe,
nous avons accepté de parler de la sécurité comme d'un jeu de somme nulle,
comme si pour augmenter la sécurité,
il fallait faire des compromis sur des valeurs et droits :
la sécurité contre les droits de l'Homme,
la sûreté contre la liberté et le développement.
C'est une opposition factice.
Cela ne fonctionne pas ainsi.
Nous devons reconnaître
que la sécurité et les droits de l'Homme ne sont pas contradictoires,
ils sont intrinsèquement liés.
Après tout, le droit de l'Homme le plus fondamental
est le droit de vivre sans violence
et la responsabilité la plus fondamentale d'un État
est de garantir ce droit à ses citoyens.
Réciproquement, si nous pensons aux communautés à travers le monde
qui sont touchées par les guerres et les conflits,
c'est l'insécurité et la violence
qui les empêchent d'obtenir leur liberté pleine et entière et leur développement.
Elles ont autant besoin que nous d'une sécurité élémentaire
et elles en ont besoin pour vivre une vie normale
et jouir des droits de l'Homme.
C'est pourquoi nous devons changer.
Nous devons reconnaître qu'une sécurité durable
s'établit sur la fondation des droits de l'Homme,
s'établit sur la promotion et le respect des droits de l'Homme.
Au cours des deux dernières décennies,
nous avons accepté que la meilleure façon de garantir notre propre sécurité
est de vaincre nos ennemis
et, pour ce faire, nous devons compter presque exclusivement sur l'armée.
A nouveau, cela s'oppose à mon travail, à ma recherche,
aux observations sur le terrain.
J'observe qu'établir une sécurité durable
a moins à voir avec le fait d'anéantir les ennemis,
a moins à voir avec la victoire sur le champ de bataille
et a plus à voir avec la protection des victimes
et le fait d'instaurer la stabilité.
Pour ce faire, l'armée seule
ne suffit simplement pas.
C'est pourquoi je crois que nous devons
mettre de côté l'éternelle guerre contre le terrorisme
et la remplacer avec des projets pour la sécurité
axés sur le principe de protection des civils,
peu importe d'où ils viennent, quel est leur passeport
ou où ils vivent :
Vancouver, New York,
Kaboul, Mossoul, Alep ou Douma.
La sécurité durable nous dit que nous avons plus de chances
d'avoir une sécurité à long terme chez nous
si nous concentrons nos engagements à l'étranger sur la protection des civils
et sur le fait d'assurer qu'ils vivent dans la dignité
et sans violence.
Par exemple, nous savons tous que renverser Daech
serait une réussite en termes de sécurité.
Absolument.
Mais reconstruire des maisons détruites,
restaurer l'ordre,
assurer un système politique représentatif,
ces choses sont tout aussi importantes, si ce n'est plus,
et pas seulement pour la sécurité des civils en Irak et en Syrie,
mais pour notre propre sécurité et pour l'équilibre mondial.
Plus fondamentalement,
le danger de Daech ne devrait pas être estimé par le nombre d'armes détenues
mais aussi le nombre d'enfants qu'ils ont empêchés d'aller à l'école
ou endoctrinés.
Cela est vrai d'un point de vue de la sécurité.
D'un point de vue de la sécurité,
l'incidence générationnelle à long terme de millions d'enfants en Syrie
grandissant en ne connaissant que la guerre et sans aller à l'école
est une menace envers la stabilité qui est bien plus dangereuse
que toutes les armes de Daech réunies
et nous devrions passer autant de temps et d'énergie à contrer cela
que nous en passons à contrer Daech militairement.
Au cours des deux dernières décennies,
notre politique de sécurité a vu à court terme.
Elle s'est concentrée sur le moment présent.
Elle a systématiquement minimisé le lien entre ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
au nom de la sécurité
et l'effet à long terme de ces choix.
Dans les années suivant le 11 septembre,
certains des choix,
certaines des politiques que nous avons mises en place
ont probablement diminué, pas augmenté notre sécurité à long terme.
Une sécurité durable, axée sur les civils
doit considérer ce qu'il se passe sur le long terme.
A nouveau, par exemple,
compter sur les drones pour cibler les ennemis dans des pays éloignés
peut être un outil.
Ce peut être un outil pour s'assurer ou pour minimiser la menace
d'une attaque imminente envers les États-Unis.
Mais qu'en est-il de l'effet à long terme ?
Si des civils sont tués,
si des communautés sont visées,
cela nourrira un cercle vicieux
de guerre, de conflit, de traumatisme et de radicalisation
et ce cercle vicieux est au cœur de nombre des défis de sécurité
auxquels nous faisons face.
Cela n'améliorera pas notre sécurité à long terme.
Nous avons besoin de sécurité civile,
nous avons besoin de sécurité durable et axée sur les civils
et nous en avons besoin maintenant.
Nous devons encourager la réflexion et la recherche autour de ce concept
afin de le mettre en place.
Nous vivons dans un monde dangereux.
Il y a beaucoup de menaces envers la paix et de conflits.
Comme dans les jours suivant le 11 septembre,
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre
de ne pas réfléchir à la sécurité internationale.
Mais nous devons tirer des leçons des 20 dernières années.
Pour bien faire les choses en termes de sécurité,
nous devons nous concentrer sur le long terme,
sur la protection des civils.
Et nous devons respecter et reconnaître le fait
qu'une sécurité durable s'établit sur la fondation des droits de l'Homme.
Autrement, au nom de la sécurité,
nous risquons de faire du monde
un lieu bien plus dangereux et instable
que celui que nous avons trouvé.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)